[Music]
it's this simple it's a battle between
those who value the core principles of
this country and those who only value
cheap political victories now from day
one Republicans have treated the
confirmation process of judge Kavanagh
with the seriousness it deserves
Democrats they have not they created
chaos at judge Kavanagh hearings
interrupting as you saw dozens of times
there were constant outbursts from
left-wing protesters disrupting the
proceedings and much more now just days
away from a formal vote after all of the
hearings were over and Senator Dianne
Feinstein she drops a bombshell an
allegation from a woman accusing judge
Kavanaugh of sexual misconduct
going back 36 years when they were both
in high school now Feinstein knew about
these allegations since July she kept
them secret now she kept them secret
when she met privately with judge
Kavanaugh she kept them secret when she
questioned Kavanaugh publicly and
Feinstein used an allegation serious
allegation of sexual misconduct as a
political ploy to delay and disrupt
Cavanaugh's confirmation now despite all
of this to their credit Republicans have
rightly taken these accusations against
judge Kavanaugh seriously as they should
a public hearing featuring both Kavanagh
and his kkuk user professor Christine
Ford has been set for Thursday tonight
there is still a chance we now have news
Ford may not appear Senator Dianne
Feinstein said she cannot guarantee that
she will show up now apparently Ford has
concerns about the independent female
attorney hired to question both Ford and
Cavanaugh Republicans clearly are trying
to do everything in their power as they
have been doing to accommodate professor
Ford now either way a committee vote on
Kavanagh has now been scheduled for this
Friday and of course judge Kavanagh has
been begging for a chance to clear his
name under oath
since these charges first became public
his categorically denied these
allegations over and over and meanwhile
virtually no evidence is backing up
professor Ford's 36 year old claim
cannot remember the date or the location
of the alleged incident even the year
the four witnesses professor Ford listed
to corroborate her story all of them
deny which he is alleging all four and
now many on the left are demanding that
the FBI investigate Ford's allegations
that no confirmation vote should take
place until the FBI weighs in remember
they knew this back in July now tonight
they should take the advice can't
believe I'm saying this of crazy uncle
Joe Biden listen to what he said way
back in 1991 the next person refers to
an FBI report as being worth anything
obviously doesn't understand anything
FBI explicitly does not in this or any
other case reach a conclusion period
period all right that means the
Democrats now it's all political they're
not listening to Joe Biden due process
the presumption of innocence literally
mean nothing to them especially Delaware
Senator Chris Coons he actually thinks
that Judge Cavanaugh has to prove his
innocence I'm not making this up
take a look so just dismiss out of hand
as a shameful smear campaign these
allegations strikes me as not what's
appropriate in this setting
it is Judge Cavanaugh who is seeking a
lifetime appointment to the Supreme
Court and who I think now bears the
burden of disproving these allegations
rather than dr. Ford and miss Ramirez
that said really that Senator remember
this the next time you talk about keith
ellison yeah the number two guy at the
DNC and Senator Chris Coons he's not
alone Democrats want a cheap political
victory at all costs
even if that means throwing inedible
rights right out the window
smearing slander besmirch bent right out
the wit they don't care watch this the
Senate shouldn't simply rely on hearing
two conflicting accounts and decide well
we're okay with not knowing we're okay
with the fact that we might be putting a
someone who committed attempted rape on
the Supreme Court of the United States I
believe her listen first of all anybody
who comes forward at this point to be
prepared to testify in the United States
Senate against someone who's being
nominated to one of the most powerful
positions in the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here
there's every reason to believe her she
has come forward courageously and
bravely I believe her I stand with her
she should be bullied into this scenario
where it's a he-said she-said it's a
sham hearing and I don't think she
should participate in it dad I believe
professor Ford
I think she's credible and I think when
the investigation is finished and when
she testifies and Judge Cavanaugh
testifies I think a majority of senators
will find her credible men shut up
oh I believe means no due process no
presumption of innocence judge Kavanagh
is also facing an additional allegation
totally uncorroborated claim from a
woman her name is Miss Deborah Ramirez
and she told the New Yorker that in the
1980s again 34 years ago Cavanaugh
exposed himself when he was a freshman
at a drunken college party at a dorm
room at Yale and get this Ramirez
herself she's not even totally sure if
Cavanaugh was the perpetrator if you
read The New Yorker column
she became quote quickly inebriated at
the party she told the Union or New
Yorker she was quote foggy and slurring
her words she even acknowledged that she
has significant memory gaps from that
evening and the New York Times was not
able to corroborate her story with
anybody and even said she called people
that went to Yale asking them if they
remember the inn
if because she didn't know if it was
Cavanaugh and those who Ramirez listed
as witnesses in that case to the
incident are all flatly denying her
charges quote we can say with confidence
that if the incident Debbie alleges ever
occurred we would have seen or heard
about it and we did not the behavior
that she describes would be completely
out of character for Brett in addition
some of us knew Debbie long after Yale
she never described this incident until
Brett Supreme Court nomination was
pending and also The New Yorker
interviewed Ramirez best friend at the
time of the incident and she also is
denying any knowledge of the claims
quote this is a woman I was best friends
with we shared intimate details of our
lives and I was never told this story by
her or by anybody else
it never came up I didn't see it I never
heard of it happening now the New York
Times they couldn't corroborate the
story in any way they refused to publish
the claims as part of their official
reporting and they said they spent all
last week interviewing dozens of people
they couldn't find one person that could
corroborate it now needless to say
chairman Grassley will not be calling
miss Ramirez to testify still despite
the lack of evidence the left of course
rushing to judgment as they have in so
many prior occasion occasions smearing
judge Cavanaugh not even wanting to hear
his side of it and rushing to judgment
saying well I believe one person this is
dangerous for anybody in society we
should all believe it should not be
political it's not Republican not
Democrat not conservative not liberal we
should believe in the presumption of
innocence but many don't watch this this
is a monumental defining moment this
week when you have someone like Cosby
going to prison and then in the same
breath having Kavanagh possibly going to
the highest court in on land does he
want America to believe that the only
thing that he did until well into his
college years was effectively kiss or
French kiss a woman is that what he
wants America to believe and to be
honest that is a very much a white male
Republican defense to say oh I was a
virgin I could
possibly sexually assaulted a woman if
they go through a Senate hearing and it
becomes a circus they push it through he
passes he's seated on the Supreme Court
right there will be as we've said last
week an asterisk next to his name as
long as he's there so if Nancy Pelosi we
have congresswoman Maxine Waters and
then the new face of the Democratic
Party
Michael avenatti all going on TV and
actually threatening to expose now a
gang rape scandal about judge Kavanagh
he's the lead guest on fake news CNN and
MSNBC conspiracy TV they love their
avenatti so just to recap we have heard
from Democrats rushing to judgment we've
heard from many in the mainstream media
rushing to judgment we've even heard
from future Democratic presidential
candidate Michael avenatti yeah again
the new face of the Democratic Party
along with others and now like sheep
following the herd the left's angry mob
is joining the stop Cavanaugh movement
last night far left activist well they
ran into senator Ted Cruz and his wife
we're just going out to a restaurant
right here in the swamp in Washington DC
while mindlessly chanting we believe
survivors what's this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the last year we played it here
you've heard people like congresswoman
Maxine Waters people like Senator Cory
Booker and year has gone by even Barack
Obama get in their face follow them into
grocery stores what you're seeing it
witnessing here is a key part of what is
the Democratic playbook we've seen these
confrontations over and over again
secretary kirsten nielsen sarah sanders
Pam Bondi is mob mentality these tactics
of the left are now in full gear 42 days
out of an election and senator Ted
Cruz's opponent by the way as a sidebar
he was just given oh four big
Pinocchio's by The Washington Post over
statements surrounding his 1998 DUI
where he literally left the scene of the
DUI accident he was at two times the
legal limit but he denied that ever
happened now if the left truly believes
survivors they might want to focus on
the Deputy Chair of their own party the
democratic party keith Ellison his
ex-girlfriend has accused him of
repeated physical and psychological and
emotional abuse dating back just a short
time ago not 36 years ago he's now
running to be the Attorney General of
the state of Minnesota he's still the
number two guy at the DNC and at a
debate last week here's what he had to
say about these recent claims take a
look are you confident that no one else
will step forward without any other
allegations look you know in this
political environment you know I don't
know what somebody might cook up but I
can tell you that there is absolutely
nobody that I'm aware of who has any
sort of through who's threatening or
suggesting or as if I've ever made
our accusation now so many of these
Democrats that will not give due process
or the presumption of innocence the
judge Cavanaugh
they haven't uttered a word about their
number two with their party and we may
soon learn more about Ellison's
treatment of women previous divorce
proceedings may be unsealed but tonight
Ellison has yet to face an angry mob
chanting we believe survivors he's yet
to be convicted on TV by congressional
Democrats by Senate Democrats neither
has a California Democratic
congressional candidate
he's accused of demanding sex in
exchange for campaign funds he's not
being criticized either neither is
former President Bill Clinton he's been
accused of so many counts of sexual
misconduct including by juanita
Broderick rape and here's what she had
to say earlier today on my radio program
take a listen
not one of them even after henry hyde
said please just read this account and
this deposition from this arkansas woman
and he said just read it we're not going
to bring her into the impeachment
hearing but just read what she has to
say
none would read it not one demand what
we have so much more on this double
standard all throughout the show by the
way and it's sad the rest of the media
won't report on this we're gonna be in
Washington DC today tomorrow and of
course Thursday for the upcoming hearing
if it happens if professor four decides
to tell her story we will listen so
while all of this is going on right here
in DC well the president well he's in
New York at the time and literally
pushing his America first agenda moving
forward with historic success and today
at the UN he stood up solidly for
America first in front of the world
stage and I think one of his best
speeches to date take a listen
in less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
America's economy is booming like never
before since my election we've added 10
trillion dollars in wealth the stock
market is at an all-time high in history
and jobless claims are at a 50-year low
that's great success for The Forgotten
men and women that came out to vote in
2016 are you gonna vote go out and vote
and keep the Republicans in Congress of
the agenda the success can continue well
some of the world leaders were laughing
at America's success guess what it's not
a joke we do have record low
unemployment in 14 states record low
unemployment african-americans Hispanic
Americans Asian Americans 65 year low
for women in the workforce in America
youth unemployment 55 year low 4 million
fewer people on food stamps 4 million
more Americans working breaking records
in the stock market consumer confidence
hitting an 18-year high and now a blue
wave well guess what tonight it may not
be so certain as the media has been
peddling to everybody look at this
Gallup poll Republican favorability out
today has now hit a seven-year high now
compare that to Obama's track record
Americans literally spent more on taxes
in the years 2013 of 2016 than they did
on food and clothing and by the way the
Democrats want their crumbs back there's
no secret to the president's success he
doesn't go on apology tours he puts
America first and it works
take a look America will always choose
independence and cooperation over global
governance control and domination I
honor the right of every nation in this
room to pursue its own customs beliefs
and traditions the United States will
not tell you how to live for work or
worship we only ask that you honor our
sovereignty in return we will not allow
our workers to be victimized our
companies to be cheated
and our wealth to be plundered and
transferred America will never apologize
for protecting its citizens we will
never surrender America sovereignty to
an unelected unaccountable global
bureaucracy America is governed by
Americans we reject the ideology of
globalism and we embrace the doctrine of
patriotism in 42 days you get to decide
if this agenda continues the choice
could not be clearer for the American
people it's the party of identity
politics versus the party of America
first the party of chaos disruption
versus the party of core principles
values the Constitution law and order
the party of big big government
regulations versus the party of economic
growth less burdensome regulations lower
taxes energy independence and yet
protecting our borders 42 days your life
is going to continue to improve or
progress will stop the fate is in your
hands the choice in November could not
be any more clear